oh that smells so good
[Music]
all right there welcome back today we
have a special guest and you've already
seen the special guest on this channel
and i'm so excited that she's doing
another recipe video with me welcome
sylvia
[Music]
thank you so sylvia here aka mama
latinas i've been following her blog
like i said previously i've been
following her blog for a while we're
actually going to be making tamales
today green chicken tamales just in time
for christmas because as you know
mexicans we love tamales for christmas
yes what should we do first okay so for
tamales the first thing we need to do is
put the leaves you know the corn hot in
water water because they're you know
they're dry
yes i mean i grew up like during
christmas helping like my mom or my
aunts like doing
i never learned how to make everything
from scratch they i would just do the
part where you just oh they [ __ ] make
it make cheese made yeah
yeah you just like spread the yeah
the meat fold it but i was a child when
i did that so i don't remember it's so
fun you know i wish i had that with my
family my family never did oh really so
i had to learn my own so we're gonna put
now the corn husks in the very hot water
so we make it really flexible and easy
to fall you know a lot of my childhood i
spend in the kitchen and maybe you do
this too with your family sometimes and
um i love to be there in the kitchen
with my family and my grandma one time
she didn't realize they were a few
servants in there
and i was not doing one of my
one of my brothers
and they touched the face and it was so
much trouble oh you know
spicy face and nice
but you know my mom used to
peel like tomatillos or clean the
frijoles oh yeah i used to love doing
that
yummy bread or whatever go to the corner
store catches in mexico there's a
there's literally a store in every
corner oh yes every single corner so
they'll send little kids all the time to
go get some stuff so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna start with the filling
okay for the tamales and uh we're gonna
blend okay the tomatillos with
the onion cilantro and
garlic oh yeah i have garlic how many
a couple just to give my little flavor
all right let me get the blender this is
a brand new blender never used it before
got a brand new baby here
[Music]
ready go for it
go for it
let's see probably and then we're gonna
add all the garlic okay and we're not
gonna do this very spicy so we're just
gonna do one rinse go for it yeah
there we go apatita we say it and then
we're gonna put the cilantro in it
put it in there all right and then we're
going to put um we're going to come over
so you do it so you learn because you're
doing everything
you know how to make lifestyles
perfect
[Music]
this smells amazing
i forgot how much we use oregano in
mexican cooking my mom came over and she
was teaching me how to make wasabi when
i put the regular time
yeah i'm like mixing my english in
spanish i was like oh my god yeah my
childhood again i totally smell the
cilantro and they already
delicious so we're gonna do one
tablespoon of salt
okay
so healthy yay
first time i'm using this give me a
second
power
[Music]
[Music]
that smells so good it's so good it
smells it has like a kick of spice
with the cilantro
we have our salsa now we need the
chicken chicken okay so i already boiled
the chicken i didn't do it casey did it
for me thank you
no my shirt
i should wear an apron we're gonna save
the chicken broth for later
[Applause]
i've never done this oh yeah i'm scared
[Applause]
it's working that's cool
and then we can just do this yeah but
that's a lot better than oh yeah
hours and hours doing this and then your
hands smell like chicken all day and you
know it's funny i
never liked cooking
but now more recently like i'm getting
older and like now like you know we're
having a another baby and then with
isaac like i feel bad that i didn't give
him a childhood of a mom that's in the
kitchen so now i really want to be more
in the kitchen i've been cooking a lot
more and now i'm like learning a lot of
things where i'm like oh okay so this is
how this works so i don't know i feel
like a newbie like a complete newbie in
the kitchen well the good thing about
cooking is that you can start at any
point that's true
yeah i'm gonna start pouring okay yes
probably we need to wet a little bit
longer but that's okay oh it wasn't hot
enough it wasn't hot oh the oil looked
like it was bubbling no i'm learning
know and i forgot to tell you that it's
a trick when you put in in this case it
was not a lot of oil so it might not
work but when you have a lot of oil and
you want to know if it's ready you put
one wooden spoon in the like this part
of the wooden spoon okay and if that
bubbling around it he's ready i grabbed
a little bit of water and i just splash
it and i'm like oh my god
is that is that ready okay it's ready
that's dangerous
i go like that and then i go do you want
a prey cook
i never do that
and you're gonna notice that the
color changes it's where you know the
automatic usually because it is really
bright
green you see it's gonna go to like
olive green oh yeah
that's cool that's pretty cool so what's
this gonna happen is it's cooking the
tomatillos and it's gonna make it a
little bit thicker
right now we're gonna add our chicken
okay okay
[Music]
i'm going to show you how my grandma
used to teach me
like just put it in your hand just put
that
just a little bit of this
okay okay and then when i start the vlog
i need to start measuring everything
because people like what is the pinch of
one
that's so typical like grandma teaching
it's just like don't you know like how
much is that yeah i know
oh that's perfect
so that's done we're done with the with
the filling filling so now we're gonna
make the masa yay
yeah so we forgot to put the onion on
the salsa oh yeah yeah yeah yeah with
all the commotion yes how you taste it
it is perfect it's good
i'm not yeah i'm not mad at it i mean
did you love onion it really adds a
little bit of flavor in this case i
think
it's okay yeah it's okay yeah but you
know what's funny i actually don't like
onion so this is perfect oh good see i
know but i knew that i knew that yeah
somehow
so the first thing we're going to do
is we are going to um i cannot even
remember the very spanish that's thing i
mean when you start speaking two
languages you're going to speak one
language correctly i'm not sure
what
[Music]
nice
look at that
yeah i should actually i totally didn't
that was gonna be that slice
it's gonna be more like this it's like
cutting into a cake and it's like one
little slice and you take the whole big
i know no it's like uh i'm just like i
just eyeballing this without don't be
afraid no it's just gonna go it's just
gonna go crazy yeah
[Music]
all right so let's make the masa okay we
cream the lard
doesn't smell like vanilla
it doesn't smell like it i mean you
expect like oh it smells so good yeah no
lovely so we are going to start adding
um the flour
and then after that is mixed we're going
to start adding the liquid which is the
chicken broth when you mix tamales i
mean you have the measurements but it is
kind of flexible because i juicing the
masa you're going to need to add more or
less right so let's just feel it yeah
[Music]
that's how it should look so if you like
touch it it's like it's like sand like
you can just make our own sand with this
like a little sandbox for the baby yeah
edible sand
so we're gonna add some
baking whatever
it's like
okay
and salt what is going to make the masa
is now the liquid which is the chicken
broth
[Music]
now i know how to make matzo yeah
i've always wanted to learn so what we
want is a consistency that is spreadable
okay but not too weight okay more like a
problem like peanut buttery
this is really
relaxing yes this is like asmr yes
oh my god that smells so good do you
think that's a spreadable oh yeah i
think that's ready and then let you do
this yeah
flatten it out
and we're gonna cover it
oh my goodness yeah
it is i'm learning curve yeah the first
time i made it was like fighting with
the with the
whole time yeah oh my gosh it's okay no
it's okay
you know you're it's the first time and
when i did it the first time yeah
exactly the same yeah thank you so much
making
it depends how much feeling you want to
add i like to add a good chunk so you
really like have a lot of feeling yeah
perfect okay you fold it in a way that
you see how they get all together yeah
yeah and then you do this
and then
you
fold it up hold it up like this try it
yep
[Music]
that is so cute here are those
our babies yeah
[Music]
okay so now let's do it
perfect i'm like come on girl speed it
up girl you gotta keep up it's just
practice practice practice
yeah because i mean i feel really guilty
that isaac grew up not knowing any
spanish not being very proud of his
culture because i'm super proud of my
culture and not being around it
constantly made me realize like oh my
gosh i didn't even ingrain it in his
life at all and so he doesn't know any
spanish he doesn't know any he doesn't
really know much about our culture and
that makes me feel super guilty yeah but
you know what we pardons we always we
feel guilty a lot about so many things
and i just think that shouldn't feel
guilty about it i mean we as partners do
the best we can
and you're doing it now right you're
bringing the food trying you're having a
new baby you're gonna speak spanish to
the baby
so isaac is gonna start hearing that too
yeah so he's gonna get from that and let
me tell you something like i don't know
you see it in iceland but in my
experience i could see my kids and i
could see the mexican part in them like
they were born with that
right so it was very beautiful to see
when they were a little older and i took
it to mexico and we live in mexico for a
year yeah and see how they were so happy
because now they understood that part of
them that they didn't understood before
that's awesome that's part of that this
is their heritage yeah so you're doing
ever you're doing it correctly tiffany
and everything you're doing right now
don't feel guilty thank you don't
because we have so much to do yeah with
our kids and you add the guilt in there
no just move forward that's true okay
the one more yeah i think there's enough
for just one more okay
we did it we did it
we did it
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know this is gonna work fine for you
yeah yeah this isn't a tamale which is
like a special pot where it has the
bottom that's it for the tamales oh we
have a steamer um
yeah we need one of these this extra one
that we have we're gonna put them in the
bottom we're gonna extend them and we're
gonna cover them you know as much as we
can cover them
so when we put the tama we're just gonna
hold it yeah
[Music]
so when you have a lot of tamales and
it's completely covered so then the end
the extra one just put them in on top
oh i'm so excited how long did it take
to cook
oh
so it's been an hour right so we're
exciting
for torture
yeah i know
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
okay i just laid it out so fast
mine doesn't slide perfect they're gonna
stick today oh yeah there you go oh my
gosh yeah they're so perfect they're
gonna be very soft because they're very
hot okay and you see i like it with a
lot of filling yes because it's nothing
nothing worse than a dry tamale with no
filling
come on how many of us have tried one of
us let us know in the comments yes how
many of you have a dry tamale oh i'm so
excited i'm gonna get
one in the
yeah and then you're gonna have two
so plus a lot like
that
[Music]
oh my god it's so good oh this is yummy
oh man
can i tell you something what
my favorite tamales are the red ones i
was always biased against green and
everything yeah these are bomb these are
so good sylvia thank you so much for
coming again joining us and making
another delicious recipe i hope you guys
enjoy these videos uh we'll continue to
make some in the future and you guys
make sure to check out her blog
mamalatinatips.com you can find all her
delicious recipes including this one let
us know if you ever make some of her
stuff because i would love to know too
especially if you make this recipe thank
you everybody for watching and i
would like to know how you like tamales
what's your favorite
okay
[Music]
you